mich persönlich beschäftigt noch ein
wenig mehr als Trump unser
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
mittlerweile wird wohl jeder von ihnen
die Impfkampagne von Lauterbach kennen
falls nicht hören wir doch einmal rein
ich schütze mich weil ich lieber mit
meinen Enkelkindern Spiele als mit
meiner Gesundheit es schütze mich weil
ich ein Quarantäne keiner Leben retten
kann ich schütze mich weil Düfte für
mich das schönste sind ja das waren
jetzt drei von 80 Protagonisten die
berichten warum sie sich gegen Corona
impfen lassen die Währung der Kampagne
sie haben schon gemerkt das sind
Emotionen doch wenn es eines während der
corona-pandemie meiner Meinung nach
genug gab dann waren das ja genau
Emotionen was uns ja fehlt sind Fakten
mich stört auch allein schon der Slogan
der Kampagne ich schütze mich wenn die
Impfung also auf Selbstschutz abzieht
warum wurden die Menschen die sich gegen
die Impfung entschieden haben dann
vergangen Winter ausgegrenzt sie merken
schon ich habe bei dem Thema ordentlich
Temperatur wenn ich mich wirklich
mittlerweile Frage was das eigentlich
soll gefährden die Menschen ohne
corona-impfung ihre Mitmenschen jetzt
also nicht für mich ist diese
Impfkampagne ein Skandal ich finde
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
sollte die Gelder endlich nutzen um die
corona-pandemie aufzuarbeiten und meine
erste Frage dein Herrn Schubert der
Staat gibt ja für diese Kampagne 800
Millionen aus ist es aus ihrer Sicht gut
angelegtes Geld es war bis dato kein
gutes angelegtes Geld in den letzten
drei Jahren und es wird auch weiterhin
nicht so sein und es wird auch in
Zukunft nicht so sein ich bin zutiefst
überzeugt wir haben eine Pandemie nicht
eines Coronavirus sondern wir eine
Pandemie des falschen Menschenbildes in
einer schlechten Wissenschaft und
wenn ich auch in der Vorbereitung auf
diese Sendung sollte uns ja auch ein
Statement überlegen und und ich bin da
auf über ein Zitat gestolpert bei den
Schließungen der Kitas in der
corona-pandemie haben wir uns geirrt
also es wird jetzt ein Irrtum zugegeben
von Karl Lauterbach und da denke ich mir
aha also 3 Millionen Kinder Kleinkinder
sind irrtümlicherweise an ihrer
Entwicklung gehemmt worden auf die Kita
Schließung kommen wir ja heute noch bei
ihrem Thema
auch noch um einmal noch bei der Impfung
zu bleiben wie sieht das denn jetzt aus
mit dem fremdschutz und dem Selbstschutz
weil ich finde die Rhetorik aus der
jetzigen Kampagne ich schütze mich ist
ja eine ganz andere als sie die letzten
Winter angebracht wurde weswegen ja
Menschen ausgegrenzt werden weil wenn
man sich nur selbst schützen kann wie es
die Kampagne ja suggeriert warum wurden
Menschen ausgegrenzt
das ist ein ideologisches Problem diese
corona-pandemie und da ist irrsinnig
viel irrational und es werden lügende
sehr gesagt es werden Menschen in Angst
und Panik versetzt es ist man kann mit
gar nicht mehr richtig diskutieren auch
auf wissenschaftlicher empirischer Ebene
das Zeug wirkt nicht ja und und es wurde
gelogen und es wurden falsche Tatsachen
vorgespielt um das offensichtlich unter
die Bevölkerung zu bringen aus welchen
Grund auch immer das unter die
Bevölkerung gebracht werden sollte aber
ich bin ein ein großer Gegner davon
Impfstoffe initionsstoffe
messenger-impfungen Menschen in diesem
großen Stil zu verabreichen vor allem
jenen denen man es nicht verabreichen
muss weil sie von kovid kaum betroffen
sind wir wissen genau welche
Risikogruppen es sind das sind sehr alte
Menschen sind sie aber schon für die
Impfung ich denke wenn jemand in eine
Risikogruppe reingekommen ist dann wird
es wahrscheinlich das klingt jetzt
zynisch auch schon egal sein aber in dem
Messenger RNI von kriegt wenn er schwer
ist Diabetes hat und Herz dann muss man
wahrscheinlich irgendetwas tun und wenn
die Menschen meinen sie sollen sie
werden sich dann impfen dann sollen sie
das tun und vielleicht wirkt da auch
Placebo ein Stück weit mit da habe ich
überhaupt kein Thema damit aber Menschen
die gesund sind ja in solche eben und
Kinder vor allem ja und mittlerweile
auch Schwangere so der offensichtlich
auch empfohlen Schwangere zu impfen das
ist ein Verbrechen aus fertig Schluss
und wenn ich da über irgendwelche Gelder
reden soll dann dann geht's einfach
weiter mit dem Verbrechen für mich ist
es eine Katastrophe es ist ein Desaster
harter Vorwurf ein Verbrechen
frage ich gerne Herrn Korte einmal
würden sie da mitgehen wie würden sie
das einstufen mich etwas gewundert ist
eine schwierige Problematik aber hier zu
hören wo es so klare Evidenzen gibt was
die Impfung bringt auch für Kinder auch
für Schwangere die einen deutlich
höheres Risiko einer Fehlgeburt haben
wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und Anco
wird 19 erkranken da wundere ich mich
ein bisschen das gerade gerade gehört
gerade gehört zu haben dazu gibt es
Daten dazu gibt es Untersuchungen und
das jetzt einfach weg zu wischen und so
zu tun dass man Menschen all diesen
Gefährdungen aussetzt gerade jungen
Müttern gerade den werdenden Kindern das
finde ich schon eigentümlich also
Schubert ist offensichtlich in der Lage
zu lesen und wissenschaftliche Literatur
zu lesen das dann zu ignorieren und
abzutun als Propaganda das finde ich
schon sehr fahrlässig also da bin ich
anderer Meinung was aber ja sicher
stimmt ist dass wir gesehen haben dass
diese Impfung kein schwarz-weiß Spiel
ist es schützt einen nicht zu 100%
selber auch das stimmt es schützt doch
nicht zu 100% andere Menschen es ist
sogar so dass drei Monate nach der
Impfung man sogar ein relativ hohes
Risiko hat sich selber noch zu
infizieren und andere Menschen zu
infizieren und es hat sich auch gezeigt
dass ja die Länder in ganz
unterschiedlich auf der Welt mit der
Pandemie umgegangen sind zum Beispiel
gab es in Japan deutlich weniger
lockdowns aber auch deutlich weniger
Tote also man sieht sagen wir und long
the line
Schubert immer betont hat dass es gibt
nicht eben eine Maßnahme Menschen zu
schützen sondern in wurde eben viel an
den eigenen an die Eigenverantwortung
der Menschen appelliert es wurden viele
Masken getragen es wurden
Risikosituationen gemieden die Impfquote
war hervorragend auch das hat natürlich
die Bevölkerung geschützt aber es gab
viel weniger lockdowns und insbesondere
Kinder und gegenüber wurde anders
umgegangen bei uns konnten und mussten
eher Kinder zu Hause bleiben als
Arbeitnehmer von zu Hause aus zu
arbeiten das sieht man wie bei uns die
Prioritäten waren und für einen
sechsjähriges Kind ein Jahr nicht mit
anderen zusammen gespielt zu haben heißt
die sechste seines Lebens sprechen wir
auf jeden Fall gleich noch und auch ganz
ausgiebig ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema
wie bewerten sie denn die Impfkampagne
die wir eben gesehen haben
Impfkampagnen sind immer riesige
Reduzierungen von komplexen
Problematiken in einzelnen Sätzen da tue
ich mich auch schwer weil man eben dazu
einlädt zu widersprechen wenn man so tut
als wenn nur eine Impfung einen schützen
kann dabei muss man sagen im Moment wenn
Leute dreimal geimpft sind und unter 60
wäre das Tragen einer Maske deutlich
wichtiger als sich impfen zu lassen denn
der Impfung ist ein Medikament in
Medikament hat eine Wirkung es hat aber
auch eine Nebenwirkung es haben alle
Medikamente und das gehört zur Impfung
auch dazu ist ihnen das einfach zu
einfach erklärt in so kurzen ich weiß
nicht ob man es anders machen kann würde
ich ich würde mir ich würde mir also ich
würde mir keine Werbung anschauen von
einem einem Professor wie mir der für 15
Minuten differenziert erklärt wie die
Situation ist hier hat man einzelne
Leute mit Einzelmeinungen gezeigt das
scheint mir zunächst mal legitim zu sein
und das was gesagt wurde war auch
richtig kann das von meinen Eltern auch
sagen die haben sich jetzt die vierte
Mal impfen lassen die sind eben auch 88
85 die haben das auch gemacht weil sie
dann freier Leben und ohne Angst mit
ihren Kindern Enkeln umgehen können also
da war das Argument schon sehr ähnlich
insofern finde ich das nicht verfehlt
wir hören mal weiter hier in der Runde
Herr Kreis wie sehen Sie denn die
Impfkampagne hat sie das jetzt überzeugt
die drei Clips mich hätte es nicht
überzeugt im Ausland ist in einigen
Ländern Impfung unter 18 mittlerweile
verboten darf nur noch auf aktives
Anraten der Ärzte überhaupt geimpft
werden die impfen Nebenwirkungen zeigen
sich als erheblich auch die Schäden dazu
werden wenig erfasst
michel hat es nicht überzeugt und die
ganzen Versprechungen die früher gemacht
worden sind ist schützt deinen Opa ich
schützt deine Mama haben sich im
Nachhinein als Lügen erwiesen es schützt
nicht andere schützt ausschließlich ein
selbst die ganze Kampagne die damals
gelaufen ist stellt sich im Nachhinein
als Lüge heraus und die Menschen die das
damals kritisiert haben die werden heute
immer noch als querdenke rechtsoffen
diffamiert ist eine ungeheuer
Möglichkeit die Menschen die damals
diese
absolut nicht evidenzbasierten Dinge in
die Welt gesetzt nicht wissenschaftlich
wie uns Herr Lauterbach heute immer noch
absolut nicht evidenzbasiert nicht
wissenschaftlich die Menschen dürfen es
immer noch sagen und die die damals
diskrimisiert haben moment mal wir
müssen erstmal abwägen great Barrington
declaration also grandiose
wissenschaftliche gesagt haben falsch
die werden halt immer noch diffamiert
also ich bin fassungslos vor allem ging
es auch um die Frage wie man das Geld
verwenden sollte sollte mal für
Aufarbeitung verwenden ich bin sehr
dankbar für Herrn Söder ich finde es ein
Wende großartig kann es nicht
nachvollziehen aber es zeigte dass man
auch die die Meinung ändern kann aber da
mal nachzufassen wer hat wann was gesagt
und erlaufen Videos von Menschen die
dann gesagt haben wer sich nicht impfen
lässt es ist sind Verbrecher und mit
Nazivergleiche Republik surf sie zeigen
mit dem Finger Nikolaus
Hauptstadtstudio diese Frau ist nicht
vom Amtsgericht verklagt worden obwohl
sie absolut rassistisch waren
eingeklagen hat und andere Menschen die
kritisch waren gegen die laufen
Strafverfahren da ist eine
Ungleichbehandlung eine Heuchelei in der
Politik bis heute das finde ich
unsäglich ich glaube diese Impfkampagne
kein bisschen Herr prame sie dürfen auch
bewerten benoten hat sie die
Impfkampagne abgeholt
professores und ich bin hier fein raus
ich bin nur ein Doktor wenn deutscher
Professor muss er zu allem was sagen
können
aber wenn deutsche Professor muss zu
allem was sagen können und ich brauche
das jetzt nicht die spreche jetzt als
privatpersonal ich habe hier keine
Expertise aber ich habe für mich
entschieden ich lasse mich impfen ich
bin zweimal geimpft gepustet zweimal
gelesen also Beispiel dafür dass man
trotzdem es kriegen kann aber ich glaube
dass der Verlauf milder ist und ich
glaube wir haben Daten dafür dass es
deutlich und die die an long Corvette
leiden vor allem in Amerika werden
irgendwann ein riesen ökonomisches und
auch soziales Problem werden da gibt's
jetzt Vorzeit Studien schon die würde
ich sagen angesprochen also jetzt nicht
der Impfstatus hat die Kampagne sie
angesprochen als Bürger abgeholt würden
Sie sagen yes we can nach der Kampagne
ja manchmal muss ja da genau wie
Fernsehen nicht immer nur für für
spezifische Leute gemacht ist so viel
wie möglich ich glaube das wird schon
Leute ansprechen ich bin jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht die Hauptzielgruppe
ich habe mich ja schon impfen lassen ich
es geht jetzt um die vielleicht Sie drei
oder sie zwei die sich noch nicht
dämpfen lassen haben sie sollen
angesprochen werden aber es funktioniert
offensichtlich nicht wie ich hier höre
ich habe meinen Impfstatus ja gar nicht
bekannt gegeben mache ich auch nicht
mehr weil ich das falsch finde ist eine
freie persönliche Entscheidung aber ist
gut wir haben ja heute ein Diplomaten in
der Runde das gefällt mir